[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer Kriege kosten
Geld das ist eine Binsenweisheit und
selbstverständlich hat auch der Kreml
jede Menge Rubel und auch einiges an
Valuta in die Hand genommen um seinen
ehrenwitzigen Krieg in der Ukraine zu
finanzieren außerdem verbrauchen Kriege
Waffen auch das kann man gut am Beispiel
Russlands beobachten nur einerseits die
Rüstungsindustrie auf Hochtouren läuft
anders als aber auch zunehmend
antiquierte Panzer und Kanonen aus
irgendwelchen abgelegenen Depot geholt
und in Richtung fortgeschickt werden
neben finanziellen materiellen und
natürlichen Ressourcen verbraucht so
einen Krieg auch mächtig humane
Ressourcen das ist jetzt zugegeben ein
wirklich euphemistische Ausdruck dafür
dass in einem Krieg sehr viele Menschen
umkommen oder dauerhaft geschädigt
werden und zwar selbst wenn man diesen
Krieg nicht auf eigenem Territorium
führt sondern bei einem Nachbarn der
sich verbissen wird diesen
Ressourcenverbrauch wollte uns heute
genauer ansehen und die Frage beleuchten
ob er Russland als Kriegspartei nicht
schlecht weg überfordert
die Lage an der Front die von unseren
Medien auf verschiedenste Weise
beschönigte dort entwickelt sich leider
äußerst negativ und hat einen starken
Einfluss auf die Situation im ganzen
Land in unseren ganzen Staat ich habe
keine Angst davor zusagen dass wir auf
die militärische Niederlage zu steuern
egoistine ehemalige oberstes russischen
militärgeheimnisses Gru und militärische
Führer der separatistischen
Volksrepublik Deutschland am ersten
April 2023 was der Ultra Nationalität
ist natürlich nicht das Russland aufgeht
sondern im Gegenteil noch mehr Menschen
und Material in die Schlacht wirft sehr
viel mehr er spricht klar und offen aus
was viele Russen noch nicht wahrhaben
wollen mit der bisherigen Mobilisierung
ist dieser Krieg nicht mehr zu gewinnen
fangen wir bei eben jenen humanen
Ressourcen an wie er wohl alle wisst hat
die russische Armee im Herbst 2022
zusätzlich zu den schon bestehenden
Truppen noch mindestens 300.000 Männer
bei einer sogenannten Teil Mobilisierung
einberufen mittlerweile dürften alle
diese
Kriegsgebiet angekommen sein viele von
ihnen sind auch schon nicht mehr am
Leben weniger bekannt ist aber die
folgende Tatsache russland will seine
Streitkräfte auf 1,5 Millionen Soldaten
aufstocken früher hielt der Kreml die
Größe der russischen Streitkräfte für
ausreichend aber das änderte sich als er
in der Ukraine und erwarteten Widerstand
und Rückschläge erlebte der russische
verteidigungsministerung unabhängig
davon angekündigt was in der Ukraine
passiert und das hat enorme Auswirkungen
wir sprechen hier von einer viel
größeren Anstrengung als es auf den
ersten Blick scheint denn bislang lag
die Personalstärke der Armee bei
bestenfalls 1,15 Millionen Mann er soll
diesen blind zufolge in Zukunft also
ständig 350.000 junge Menschen mehr in
Uniform geben als bislang gut bei dieser
Zahl handelt es sich um eine ziemlich
grobeschätzung und wir wissen nicht so
recht wie viele von ihnen vielleicht
schon wieder zurückgekehrt sind aber
genauso wenig wissen wir wie viele
Russen sich gegenwärtlich bei Oma auf
dem Dorf bei Fronten in einer anderen
Stadt oder auf der einsam gelegene
Familien halten natürlich kennen wir
alle die Gründe warum nicht abgetaucht
sind sie wollen schlichtweg nicht als
Reservisten eingezogen werden um dann in
einem feuchten Schützengraben im Don was
zu enden das heißt um dort dann mit
relativ hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit Elend
zu verändern und auf der anderen Seite
bleibt ein nüchterner Fakt übrig wer das
Land verlassen hat arbeitet dort nicht
mehr Zeit dort keine Steuern mehr und
Gründe dort auch keine Familien mehr das
gleiche gilt auch für die von Russland
in diesem Krieg schon erlittenen
Verluste Moskau nennt dazu genauso wie
KEF schon lange keine konkreten Zahlen
mehr warum nun die Nennung von hohen
Verlustzahlen des Gegners und geringen
oder gar keine auf der einen Seite ist
ein ganz simples Propaganda Mittel wir
nennen deshalb mit aller Vorsicht in
Bezug auf Russland drei Zahlen aus drei
verschiedenen Quellen der ukrainische
generalstoff sprach Ende März 2023 von
173.000 gefallenen Russen der NATO
Oberbefehlshaber für Europa general
Christopher Cavalli nannte Anfang März
die Zahl von 200.000 gefallenen oder
Verwundeten auf russische Seite und aus
Russland meldet general SWR einen
geheimnisvoller telegram Kanal
oppositionell Insider am ersten April
die Zahl von 238
000 eigenen Verlusten angeblich berühmt
auf eine internen Statistik die jede
Woche Putin persönlich vorgelegt wird
kurz um das sind horrende Zahl
agieren wir mal zusammen circa 400.000
die ist mobil gemacht beziehungsweise in
Zukunft zusätzlich einberuf des Soldaten
ca 700.000 abgewanderte Exilanten oder
untergetauchte und ca 200.000 Gefallene
und
kriegs-3 Millionen Menschen die der
russischen Zivilgesellschaft unter
Wirtschaft schon wählen und Russland ist
zwar ein großes Land aber um euch ein
Anhaltspunkt zu geben dies entspricht
etwa 10% aller Russen in der
Altersklasse zwischen 19 und 29 Jahren
das ist nun schon ein spürbarer
Einschnitt für ein Land in dem es
aufgrund der niedrigen Geburtenrate in
den unsicheren ersten nach sowjetischen
Jahren ohne hin nicht übermäßig viele
junge Menschen gibt zudem hatte Russland
schon vor dem Ukraine kriegt gewaltige
demografische Probleme einerseits eine
schon wieder sehr niedrige Geburtenrate
und gerade jetzt in den 2020er Jahren
kommt diese schmale Generation aus den
schwierigen 1990er Jahren ins Fort
fassungswege Alter und nicht zu
vergessen direkt vor dem Krieg rasierte
19 die Übersterblichkeit in Russland
betrug gewaltige 1,26 Millionen Menschen
Russland verlor also der pandemiejahre
fast ein Prozent seiner Bevölkerung es
ist und bleibt eine gigantische
Herausforderung für diese schrumpfende
Gesellschaft weitere Hunderttausende von
Menschen für die Streitkräfte
bereitzustellen und selbst wenn es
gelingt müssen diese Massen von ihr noch
ausgestattet unterhalten und bezahlt
werden ebenso sehen wir eine riesige
Herausforderung für die russische
Wirtschaft weil dieses von uns grob auf
1,3 Millionen geschätzte Minus an
Menschen nicht mehr als Arbeitskräfte
zur Verfügung steht und als Konsumenten
übrigens auch nicht
gemäß der Prognosen die wir vor der
Pandemie erstellt haben wird die Zahl
der Arbeitnehmer im Alter von 20 bis 40
Jahren bis zum Jahr 2030 gegenüber dem
Jahr 2020 um etwa eine viertel
zurückgehen das ist an sich schon eine
tektonische Verschiebung und wird große
Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft haben
dazu kommen noch die Verluste die wir
heute erleben also die Flucht von
Fachkräften und jungen Menschen die für
den Krieg mobilisiert werden dr Wladimir
gimpelson Direktor des Zentrums für
Arbeitsmarkt Studien an der Moskauer
haierschool of iconomics die human
Ressourcen sind aber nicht das einzige
Problem das mal einen Blick auf diese
Grafik
[Musik]
wie ihr hier sehen könnt hat Russland
begonnen seine Militärausgaben stark
hochzufahren logisch das Land befindet
sich ja im Krieg und es hat sich darauf
vorbereitet wie ihr seht sind die
Militärausgaben von 2021 auf 2022 um 50%
gestiegen und vergesst nicht das
Russland vorher auch schon nicht wenig
für die Verteidigung ausgegeben hat wenn
die NATO sich verpflichtet hat 2% des
BIP für Militärausgaben auszugeben und
bis jetzt haben nur wenige
Mitgliedstaaten diesen Wert erreicht so
ist ein Russland fast nie unter 3%
gesunken außerdem hat Russland in der
Ukraine schon eine enorme Menge an
militärischen Gerät verloren die Rede
ist von über 2.300 Panzern tausenden von
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen hunderten von
Artillerie System 12 Kriegsschiffen fast
140 kann Flugzeugen und Hubschraubern
und natürlich aber tausenden von Tonnen
an Raketen und Munition aller Art laut
einer Analyse des estnischen
Verteidigungsministeriums verbraucht die
russische Armee allein ca 10 mal so
viele Artillerie geschossen wie die
Ukraine etwa 20.000 bis 60.000 pro Tag
für diesen Kassen Unterschied gibt es
ganz handfeste Gründe die Russen können
mit viel geringer Präzision schießen
sind sowohl beim technischen Niveau als
auf der Aufklärung hoffnungslos
unterlegen und müssen daher im Gegensatz
zu den Ukrainern viel mehr Munition
verballern um eine vergleichbare Wirkung
zu erzielen wenn überhaupt aber was
bedeutet das langfristig kann Russland
wirklich zehnmal mehr Munition
herstellen als die Ukraine und ihre
Verbündeten nur den Augenblick auf gar
keinen Fall weswegen sich die Zahl der
Geschosse seit dem Herbst auch schon
drastisch reduziert hat auf nur noch 23
000 pro Tag aber auch diese Feuerrate
stellt einen Verbrauch da den die
russische Rüstungsproduktion in ihrem
jetzigen Zustand nicht mal im Ansatz zu
kompensieren in der Lage ist wenn Moskau
sein Arsenal also wieder aufstocken will
muss es sich in den nächsten Jahren
gewaltig ins Zeug legen und eine
gewaltige Menge Hobel investieren und
darin wären die laufenden
Kriegsanstrengungen noch gar nicht mit
eingerechnet wenn der Krieg ist er noch
lange nicht zu Ende vermutlich ganz im
Gegenteil natürlich wäre eine solche
Aufrüstung oder wieder Aufrüstung an
sich schon eine große Herausforderung
aber mit den massiv einbrechenden
rohstoffeinnahmen und eine Wirtschaft
die nicht weg sondern ständig Situation
geschwächt und bestraft ist ist sie noch
größer
ja das stimmt das Russland Wirtschaft in
Sanktionen mehr oder weniger Stand
gehalten hat und bisher sozusagen mit
einem blauen Auge davon gekommen ist
aber für die Zukunft sieht es weniger
rosig aus darüber haben wir kürzlich
hier auf diese Politik schon berichtet
das entsprechende Video habe ich euch
verlinkt hinzu kommt noch das als Ball
vom Besten die gefürchteten sekundär
Sanktion verabschiedet werden das ist
eine Art von Sanktion die nicht Russland
bestraft sondern andere Länder und
Unternehmen die mit Russland Hand
treiben das könnte es Russland natürlich
noch viel schwieriger machen die
Sanktionen zu umgehen reagiert hat
beispielsweise unlängst die Türkei
Türkei es ist erste Russland Sanktion um
Erdogan muss zurückstecken bisher setzte
die Türkei obwohl Mitglieder NATO keine
der vom besten gegen Russland verhängten
Sanktion um sie wurde damit zur
wichtigsten Drehscheibe des russischen
Außenhandels aber das ändert sich jetzt
Anfang März stoppte die türkische
Regierung den bis dahin florierenden
westlich sanktionierte Güter nach
Russland an karah habe den USA und der
EU mündlich zu das keine waren mehr nach
Russland gelangen die unter die
Sanktionen fallen das berichten
westliche Diplomaten wenn sich diese
Entwicklungen weiter fortsetzen könnten
sie Russland gerade zu Schach matt
setzen also wir diagnostizieren bei
Russland viel mehr Militärausgaben
gleichzeitig weniger Arbeitskräfte und
weniger Geld zonischerweise könnte man
denken dass Russland dadurch am Ende zu
einer Art großen nordkorea wird also zu
einem Land in dem die meisten Ressourcen
für die Streitkräfte drauf geben und ein
erträglicher Teil wohl auch für den
extravaganten Lebensstil des Diktators
und seine autorage in nordkoreal dreht
sich alles wirklich alles um das Militär
die nationale Verteidigung und den
Personenkult des großen Führers auf
dieses Szenario steuert Russland zwar zu
ist von nordkoreanischen Verhältnissen
wenn noch weit entfernt nichtsdestotrotz
nehmen sich nun auch die man hören sogar
offiziellen Anzeichen dass dem Kreml das
Geld ausgeben könnte zuerst gab Puten im
März das erste Mal öffentlich zu dass
die Sanktionen der russischen Wirtschaft
tatsächlich zusetzen vorher pflegte er
sorgsam dass narrativ sie würden
Russland nur stärker und selbstständiger
machen da stellte sich natürlich die
Frage wieso sich Russland da nicht schon
seit Jahren selbst sanktioniert hat aber
gut ja und jetzt ist auch noch
durchgesägter das Putin auf Battle Tour
bei seinen Freunden geht
Russland möchte Geld von befreundeten
Staaten um seinen Krieg in der Ukraine
indirekt zu unterstützen sucht der
britische Geheimdienst die Entscheidung
würde es Investoren aus anderen Ländern
ermöglichen russische Staatsanleihen zu
kaufen und einen Teil der zukünftigen
haushaltsdefizierte Russland zu
finanzieren in den letzten Monaten waren
russische Banken die wichtigsten Käufer
von russischen Staatsanleihen diese sind
jedoch wahrscheinlich nicht in der Lage
die erwarteten zukünftigen
Haushaltsdefizite vollständig zu
finanzieren russische Regierungsbeamte
sehen die Emission von Auslandsschulden
wahrscheinlich als eine Möglichkeit
Lücken in Russland Finanzen zu schließen
während sie für einen langen Krieg in
der Ukraine planen russland will also
quasi Kriegsanleihen im Ausland auflegen
da seine Banken den Staat nicht mehr
finanzieren können aber zur tragischen
Rolle der russischen Banken kommen wir
noch am Ende dieses Videos bis dahin
müssten wir noch ein paar andere
drängende Fragen beantworten wie steht
es um die aktuelle Rüstungsproduktion
Russlands vollzieht sich die
Transformation der russischen Wirtschaft
in eine Kriegswirtschaft woher soll all
das Geld kommen um den geplanten langen
Krieg zu finanzieren und welche dann
könnte das alles für die russische
Wirtschaft haben all diese Fragen und
noch ein paar mehr werden wir heute
natürlich beantworten und zwar gleich
nachdem ich euch einen kleinen Einblick
in meinen persönlichen Tagesablauf
gegeben habe in diesem Zusammenhang bin
ich nämlich auf eine sehr praktisches
Produkt gestoßen dass ich Euch gerne
vorstellen würde LG one unseres neuen
Sponsors athletic Greens wir werden ja
immer wieder gefragt wie wir es
eigentlich schaffen schon über 3 Jahre
so viele hochwertig und aufwendige
Videos und so kurzer Zeit zu drehen und
in Serie herauszubringen und das ohne
auszubrennen klar wir haben mittlerweile
ein starkes und eingespieltes Team aber
ehrlich gesagt mein persönliches
Arbeitsperson wird dadurch nicht
geringer denn auch wenn mehr Kollegen
bei der Vorbereitung eines Videos und
die Arme greifen lass ich es mir
meistens nicht nehmen dann doch eben
noch etwas mehr Qualität herauszukitzeln
schließlich geht es ja nicht darum dass
man unbedingt leistungsfähig sein muss
sondern dass man leistungsfähig sein
will weil Leistung eben Spaß macht nicht
wahr der Schlüssel dazu ist allerdings
geistige und körperliche Fitness und vor
allem eine gute Routine Routinen sind
essentiell um unseren Alltag zu
strukturieren und Körper und Geist auf
Kurs zu halten bei mir sieht diese so
aus dass ich als Nachteule nach dem
Aufstehen und vor dem Frühstück erstmal
meinen Kreislauf und meine Mitochondrien
in Schwung bringen muss ideal ist da für
mich ein wenig Sport hauptsächlich
Krafttraining allerdings kommt davor
noch etwas anderes wichtig ist der
Körper will mit Wasser und wichtigen
Nährstoffen versorgt werden allerdings
ohne ihn zu belasten und an dieser
Stelle kommt LG1 von Atlantic greenshot
spielen mit seinen 75 hochwertigen
Inhaltsstoffen Vitamin Mineralstoffen
Botanicals und Bakterienkulturen gibt es
einem genau für diese aktivierende
Morgenroutine den umfassenden
nährstoffkickt und aktiv und unbelastet
in den Tag zu starten das tolle daran es
ist sehr einfach in der Anwendung aber
seine Mikronährstoffe wurden aus echten
natürlichen Nahrungsmitteln wie Erbsen
Soja oder Chlorella geworden außerdem
sind sie in hoher Bioverfügbarkeit
vorhanden so dass sie besonders gut vom
Körper aufgenommen werden können ja und
darüber hinaus aus schmeckt es auch noch
gut mir zu wenig ist aber wartet hier
kommt der Beweis
eine einzige Portion LG das heißt ein
Messlöffel in 250 ml Wasser versorgt
mein Körper nach dem Aufstehen mit
vielen wichtigen Nährstoffen und dann
geht's gleich raus in den Garten um mit
reichlich Sonnenlicht und Bewegung
meinen ca dialen Rhythmus und
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung zu
bringen und den Serotoninspiegel
anzuheben dadurch bin ich automatisch
wacher besser gelaunt und stelle meine
innere Uhr ein und tagsüber
leistungsfähig für das recherchieren
schreiben und Filme zu sein und abends
trotz aller Krisen dieser Welt über dich
dabei nachdenken und Berichten musste
gut einschlafen zu können also so sieht
mein Start in den Tag aus schreibt mir
doch in die Kommentare wie eure
Morgenroutine aussieht und falls Sie
nicht zu ideal ist wie bei mir schreibt
mir doch wie ihr sie auf Vordermann zu
bringen gedenkt denn mein Tipp lautet
fülle dein Grundbedarf nach dem
Aufstehen mit LG one wieder auf und dann
ab nach draußen gerade jetzt wo es
wieder schön wird passend dazu bietet es
letics unsere Community ein exklusives
früheres Angebot wenn du über den Link
in der Videobeschreibung gehst erhältst
du bei Abschluss eines monatlichen ab
einen kostenlosen Jahresvorrat an
Vitamin D3 und K2 und 5 praktische LG1
travel Packs für unterwegs gratis
neukunden erhalten außerdem das LG1
welcome Cat inklusive schicker
Aufbewahrungsdose und einen praktischen
Shaker zur Monatspackung dazu ach und
vor dem Abo brauchst du auch keine Angst
zu haben du kannst es nämlich jederzeit
pausieren kündigen oder den
lieferrhythmus nach Belieben anpassen
aber das ist noch nicht alles um dir die
Entscheidung noch leichter zu machen
bietet LG und eine 90 Tage Geld zurück
Garantie stellst du also nach drei
Monaten fest dass es doch nicht zu Dir
passt bekommst du das Geld für die erste
Bestellung einfach wieder zurück ohne
dass du dafür irgendwelche Gründe
angeben musst also worauf wartet ihr
noch probiert LG Bonn doch einfach mal
aus und bringt eure Ernährung und
Routine auch auf Vordermann und schreibt
mir danach hier in den angepinnten
Kommentar wie eure Erfahrungen waren und
ob es euch auch so schmeckt wie mir so
und nun wieder zurück zum Thema und zur
Beantwortung unserer brennenden Fragen
woher will Putin all das Geld für seinen
langen Krieg hernehmen und was wird dies
für die russische ische Wirtschaft
bedeuten aufgepasst
[Musik]
eine Frage der Prioritäten
wie ist es möglich dass ein Land mit
einem Bruttoinlandsprodukt auf dem
Niveau von Italien Kanada oder Brasilien
als militärische großmachtgeld oder sich
zumindest selbst dafür hielt könnt ihr
euch vielleicht daran erinnern dass wir
jemals ein Video über die italienische
brasilianische oder kanadische Armee
gemacht hätten indem es Gießen hätte sie
machen sich gerade daran die Welt zu
erobern oder wenigstens den einen oder
anderen Nachbarstaat nein Fehlanzeige
aber im Falle Russland war die Präsenz
der Streitkräfte immer immens in der Tat
war genau das Putins oberste Priorität
während seiner über 20-jährigen
Herrschaft die Streitkräfte zu erneuern
und zu stärken um dies zu erreichen
wurden ziemlich viele andere Dinge
vernachlässigt hinten angestellt oder
gar ganz ausgelassen zum Beispiel haben
über 20% der russischen Haushalte kein
fließendes Wasser und keinen
kanalisationsanschluss verkürzt gesagt
vor allem auf dem platten Land und im
hohen Norden ist das Plumpsklo so ein
Häuschen mit Herzchen auf dem Hof nach
wie vor der Hygienestandard es hat also
nach wie vor an der elementarsten
Infrastruktur ein anderes Beispiel
Russland vielen Brücken in den
Vereinigten Staaten gibt es etwa 600.000
Brücken Russland das 1,7 mal größer ist
hat nur 40.000 bis 70.000 Brücken so
genau scheint das da eh keiner zu wissen
und wenn es keine Brücken gibt kann man
auch gleich eine russische Sprichwort
bemühen in Russland gibt es keine
Straßen nur Richtungen es scheint also
als hätte Russland schon immer so viel
fürs Militär ausgeben können weil es
eben anderswo nichts investiert hat
übrigens war das schon in der Sowjet Ära
der Fall und unterhielt sie auch nicht
viel anders aber natürlich sind unter
dem Kriegsherr Putin in dem
Militärausgaben einfach unantastbar
schaut euch an
wie ihr dieser Grafik entnehmen könnt
hat vladine Putin ab 2012 damit begonnen
Russland Militärausgaben zu erhöhen und
wird dies in den nächsten Jahren noch
stärker tun die Militärausgaben werden
damit wohl weit über 5% des BIP liegen
und nicht nur das Putins Regierung gab
nicht nur viel mehr Geld für das Militär
aus seinen Betrieb auch ihren berühmten
Plan von der Festung Russland voran das
ist eine Strategie die darauf abzielt
sich auf einen Krieg vorzubereiten und
falls nötig internationalen Sanktionen
widerstehen zu können sie haben zum
Beispiel die Auslandsverschuldung
reduziert die der wiesenreserven erhöht
und versucht die Beziehung zu Asien und
dem Nahen Osten zu stärken wir können
inzwischen annehmen dass es über Jahre
in erster Linie nicht darum ging auf
diese Weise die Wirtschaft zu stärken
sondern darum das Land auf einen Krieg
vorzubereiten darüber haben wir übrigens
schon in mehreren Videos gesprochen und
in gewisser Weise hat das alles den
Kreml ermöglicht der Bestrafung durch
den besten den letzten Jahren so gut zu
widerstehen und nun fragen wir uns alle
natürlich schönen gut aber ist diese
Vorarbeiten wirklich ausreichend um die
kriegsanstrengung weiter aufrecht zu
erhalten mit anderen Worten was tut
Russland um eine große Wirtschaftskrise
zu vermeiden und zugleich den Krieg
weiter finanzieren zu können Null im
Grunde Unternehmen drei Dinge um die
Sanktion abzubuchen
erstens versucht er seine Öl- und
gasverkäufe an Länder wie China oder in
den so weit wie möglich zu steigern um
den Verlust einer Kunden in Europa
auszugleichen im Jahr 2022 liegt das
dank höhere Öl und Gaspreise relativ gut
denn Russland konnte fast 20% mehr
einnehmen aber 2023 und in den nächsten
Jahren könnte es anders aussehen wenn es
dem Land nicht gelingt viel viel mehr
nach Asien zu verkaufen das ist
Russlands erstes großes Ziel aber es ist
nicht so einfach zu erreichen das liegt
zum einen daran dass es kaum Pipelines
in diese Richtung gibt und dass die
Transsibirische Eisenbahn schon jetzt
überlastet ist aber es liegt auch daran
dass es dich lesen anders als die
Deutschen fast alle anderen europäischen
Länder mit Energie Sicherheit ziemlich
ernst meinen und sich nicht zu sehr von
einem großen Lieferanten abhängig machen
wollen die zweite Sache die Russland tut
ist auf diesen Märkten zwischen Händler
einzusetzen die gute Verbindung zur
russischen Regierung haben sie kaufen
russisches Öl mit Rabatt um es dann den
anderen Ländern zu Marktpreisen weiter
zu verkaufen das alles natürlich gegen
eine saftige Provision an den Kremmen
mit anderen Worten der besten deckelt
den Preis für ein Barrel russisches Öl
auf 60 Dollar kein Problem ich nutze
halt ein russisches Unternehmen in
Indien dass das fast zu 60 Dollar kauft
und ist dann am indische Händler oder
eine internationalen Markt nur knapp
unter Marktpreis verkauft die Differenz
wird von Russland einkassiert auf diese
Weise können die Russen die Ölpreis
Obergrenze umgehen
und schließlich gibt es eine dritte
Strategie aus Drittländern werden
sanktionsgüter oder waren grau
importiert deren Hersteller Russland
nicht mehr direkt beliefern wollen oder
können die Russen nennen dies übrigens
den parallelen Import das ganze
funktioniert folgendermaßen Russland
kann keine westliche Technologie mehr
kaufen mir Problem Länder die Kasachstan
oder Kirgisistan die nicht sanktioniert
sind importieren was immer in Russland
benötigt wird und verkaufen es an
Russland weiter das erklärt warum z.B
den Portal Armenien im Jahr 2020
plötzlich rapide in die Höhe gestellt
sind natürlich ist dieses
umgebungsverfahren teuer und ineffizient
die Mengen sind begrenzt und was man
erhält ist nicht immer die neueste
Technologie aber es reicht aus um die
schlimmsten Lücken zu schließen zum
Beispiel um weiterhin elektronische
Steuerung für Waffensysteme zu
produzieren
diese Strategie könnte natürlich noch
scheitern wenn der besten schärfer das
sekundär Sanktion verhängt zu diesem
Thema wird von uns ein separates Video
geben aber diese drei Tricks erklären in
gewisser weißer warum Russland mit den
Sanktionen besser als erwartet fertig
werden konnte allerdings braucht der
Kreml mehr es reicht nicht aus nur den
Schlägen zu widerstehen er muss seine
Armee weiter aufrüsten und ausbauen er
muss versuchen den zunehmend moderneren
Waffensystem die die Ukraine aus dem
Westen erhält irgendwas halbwegs
Gleichwertiges entgegenzusetzen aber
kann das gelingen nun das werden wir uns
jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
Russlands Achillesferse
wir alle wissen auch diejenigen die es
nicht zugeben wollen der Krieg in der
Ukraine läuft für die russische Armee
verdammt mies ich möchte hier jetzt
nicht noch mal weit ausholen zu den
Hauptgründen warum die russische Armee
scheitert haben wir hier offiziell
Produkte eine ganze Reihe von Videos
gemacht schaut ruhig mal unten in die
Links in der Videobeschreibung und falls
Ihr uns nicht glaubt die russischen
militärblogger sagen mittlerweile das
gleiche schließlich machen Nachrichten
wie die folgende deutlich wie die Dinge
wirklich stehen die Armee hat nichts neu
eingezogene russische Soldaten beklagen
mangelhafte Versorgung wegen Diebstahl
Korruption und schlechte Logistik müssen
Angehörige selbst Ausrüstung und
Kleidung für frauensoldaten kaufen in
dieser Richtung gibt es aber noch mehr
Probleme den neuen Soldaten und Rekruten
fehlt ist nicht nur ein Ausrüstung sie
haben oft auch praktisch keine
Ausbildung erhalten und wenn sie an der
Front sind kommt ihre Verpflegung oft
verspätet oder verdorben an es fehlt
selbst an primitivsten Unterständen wo
sie Schutz finden können die sollen sich
die meisten selbst bauen aber es kam vor
dass ihnen selbst dazu ganz banal die
Schaufeln Sparten und sägen fehlten und
es ist nicht nur so dass diese Soldaten
kaum Ausrüstung Training und Nachschub
erhalten sie werden oft auch noch
misshandelt wir haben euch in früheren
Videos ja schon früher vom Phänomen der
getov China erzählt wenn neue Soldaten
planmäßig von dienstälteren Kameraden
und Offizieren grausam schikaniert
werden aber den jedoch schöner ist der
reinste Kinderkram gegenüber dem was in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten immer
wieder von russischen Soldaten selbst
aus dem Kampfgebiet berichtet wird von
der guten alten wenn das der Führer nur
wüsste Illusion besehlt drehen sie in
Gruppen nie alleine Videobotschaften mit
bitterklagenden Appellen gerichtet an
den Oberkommandierenden Putin den
Verteidigungsminister ihren Provinz oder
Ihre Angehörigen und immer Flehen Sie
sie an ihnen doch zu helfen
diese einfachen Soldaten sind
verzweifelt dass sie als Infanterie
Sturmtruppen eingesetzt würden obwohl
man sie für andere Aufgaben eingezogen
und ausgebildet habe sie fordern endlich
die soliden hobelzahlungen zu bekommen
die man ihnen bei der Aufnahme in die
Armee als zugesichert hatte sie klagen
das verwundete und Kranke nicht
evakuiert und hinreichend behandelt
worden und das schlimmste sie beklagen
dass ihre alten Vorgesetzten sie im
Stich gelassen und an obstkurve
Kommentare der don-wasserparatisten
weitergereicht hätten die sich eine
Dreck um ihre Versorgung ihre Ausrüstung
und ihre Überlebenschancen kümmern und
sollten sie sich weigern unter diesen
Bedingungen gegen die ukrainischen
Linien anzustimmen so stehen hinter
ihnen sperreinheiten das sind Killer
Truppen wie sie einst und das Zahlen im
Zweiten Weltkrieg eingesetzt worden
diese schießen dann die eigenen Leute
einfach über den Haufen wenn Sie die
Befehl nicht befolgen oder sich
zurückziehen wollen kurz um Russland
einfaches Soldaten werden auch
unmenschlichste Weise wie Kanone Futter
behandelt hinzukommen vielen der
Ausrüstung und Proviant mangelnde
Vorbereitung Löcher in der Befehlskette
das ist das perfekte Rezept für
scheitern und es erklärt was gegenwärtig
an der Front passiert oder eben nicht
passiert Russlands große erwartete
Winteroffensive im dornbas ist
jedenfalls unsichtbar geblieben meint
ihr Putin hätte vor einem Jahr gedacht
dass sein epochaler Feldzug seine
zweitgrößten Armee der Welt um eine
Kleinstadt namens Barut kumuliert naja
unabhängig davon was Putin gedacht hat
oder denkt die Moral seine Truppe ist
definitiv auf dem Tiefpunkt
selbst auf Russland Propaganda Kanälen
redet man nun davon dass alles bald die
Ukraine zum Gegenangriff übergeht man
davor wenn alle gelieferten Leopards
Abrams Marder und anderen modernen
Waffensysteme samt deren ausgebildeter
Besatzungen zum einsatzbereit stehen nun
stellt sich uns also die Frage was man
angesichts dieser fatalen Situation in
Moskau vor hat ich meine nicht
kriegerisch an der Front Fragen von
Militär Strategie und Taktik klammern
wir jetzt mal aus um sie in einem
eigenen Video auseinanderzunehmen heute
konzentrieren wir uns nur auf den
militärischen industriellen komplex wie
auch die Husten ihre Rüstungsindustrie
so schön bürokratisch nennen
wir haben ja bereits gesehen wie
moskosmetiker-ausgaben in die Höhe
geschnellt sind jetzt hat Putin seine
Regierung aufgefordert die
Rüstungsindustrie mit neuen Aufträgen zu
versorgen das Problem dabei und das
Problem ist dass Korruption eine
gewaltiges technologiedefizite
Sanktionen und geringe Produktivität
dies zu einer besonders schwierigen
Aufgabe machen und zwar selbst wenn Sie
bestimmte Komponenten über Transitländer
die armen beschaffen können erschwerend
kommt hinzu dass die russische Regierung
ihre Rüstungsaufträge im Jahr 2020
reduziert hatte das hat dazu geführt
dass viele Produktionslinien heute
geschlossen sind während das Land z.B
zwischen 2011 und 2020 jährlich zwischen
8 und 12 su34 Bomber produzierte sieht
der Vertrag von 2021 bis 2024 nur noch
die Produktion von 5 Bomben pro Jahr vor
das gleiche gilt für einige
Lenkflugkörper wie die tornado-klasse in
diesem Fall haben wir Daten für die
Modelle 9 m 544 und 9 m 549 es handelt
sich dabei um Lenkflugkörper mit einer
Reichweite von etwa 150 km im Jahr 2017
wurden zwischen 220 und 230 Stück
produziert ein Jahr später im Jahr 2018
sank die Produktion dann auf etwa 150
und im Prinzip gibt es keine Hinweise
darauf dass die Fabrik die Produktion
erhöhen könnte warum nun hauptsächlich
wegen des Mannes an Arbeitskräfte es
wird geschätzt dass die russische
Industrie etwa 400.000 neue Fachkräfte
bräuchte um den Produktionsbedarf zu
decken ihr könnt euch vorstellen dass es
wegen der exzellanten die das Land
verlassen haben und ihnen die schon in
den Krieg gezogen sind noch mehr Mangel
an Arbeitskräften gibt doch um moderne
Waffen herzustellen brauchst du neben
highte Komponenten auch
hochqualifizierte aber Russland verliert
gerade seine besten Fachkräfte ganz
besonders im IT-Bereich gleichzeitig hat
Moskau enorme Schwierigkeiten
qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte aus dem
Ausland anzuwerden denn Arbeitsmigration
nach Russland gibt es hauptsächlich die
aus mittelasiatischen Ländern wie
Usbekistan und kirgisis da aber von dort
kommen kaum Leute mit entsprechend hoher
Qualifikation Moskaus üppige
Militärausgaben werden also
hauptsächlich in die Herstellung eher
schlichte und etwas altertümlicher
Waffen fließen hauptsächlich in
Artillerie und Panzermodelle aus der
Sowjet Zeit und dabei befindet sich die
russische Rüstungsindustrie bereits
jetzt in eine Art Mangelwirtschaft wie
man sie in Deutschland zum Beispiel aus
den letzten beiden Kriegsjahren des
ersten oder zweiten Weltkriegs kennt das
bedeutet statt modernen Kriegsgerät
schafft man es gerade mal irgendwas
halbwegs kampffähiges aus dem letzten
Schock zusammen zu schweißen in der
einzigen russischen Panzerfabrik Ural
Wagon Sabo zum Beispiel laufen monatlich
gerade mal 20 neue Kampfpanzer des
aktuellen Typs T9 sich vom Band das
allerdings ist viel zu wenig um den
Verschleiß an der Frau zu befriedigen
daher weicht man als notbehälter darauf
aus erzielte Land vor sich hinrostende
T-72 aus irgendwelchen Depot zu holen
und wieder entstand zu setzen 80 bis 90
secondhand Panzer pro Monat sollen dann
gegen die Leopard Challenge und abbremse
der Ukraine antreten na dann mal viel
Glück aber apropos mangelwirtschaften
was passiert eigentlich mit dem zivilen
Rest der russischen Wirtschaft wird
diese nicht gerade in einer
Kriegswirtschaft transformiert und
könnte nicht gerade dies Putin wieder
aus der Patsche helfen nur lass uns das
doch lieber etwas genauer unter die Lupe
nehmen aufgepasst
[Musik]
lecker und fertig
manche behaupten ja Russland würde jetzt
in eine permanente Kriegswirtschaft
transformiert werden eine riesengroßes
Nordkorea so eine Gleichsetzung von
Russland und Nordkorea gibt zwar eine
schöne clickbait-schlagzeile aber die
Dimensionen und Strukturen sind dann
doch nicht vergleichbar nach Schätzungen
der USA hat Nordkorea 2021 etwa 26%
seines BIP für Verteidigung ausgegeben
im Falle russland sieht das
worst-szenario momentan 6 % vor und
Russland verfügt zudem über eine viel
stärker diversifizierte Wirtschaft als
Kind abgeschottetes Staatswesen
Putins Parade Argument war ja dass die
internationalen Sanktion kaum
Auswirkungen auf die Lebensstandard der
Russen hätten zumindest bis vor einer
Weile noch aber wenn er plötzlich eine
Kriegswirtschaft verordnen und viele
Unternehmen dazu zwingen würde
ausschließlich fürs Militär zu arbeiten
könnte sich das Bild komplett ändern es
käme schnell zu waren defizierten auf
die Märkten Vorräte würden ausgehen die
Inflation gegen mit Sicherheit durch die
Decke und wenn sich der kriegt dann auch
noch in die Länge ziehen sollte könnten
die Folgen schnell katastrophal sein die
Wirtschaftslage ist also eines der
großen Probleme die in Zukunft über das
Wohl und Wehe der russischen Armee
entscheidet denn die Rüstungsindustrie
braucht Maschinen Arbeitskräfte und alle
Arten von Nachschub an komplexen
Materialien und Komponenten gleichzeitig
muss der Krämer jedoch die russischen
Konsumenten bei Laune halten
und das meine Lieben
visualpolitikzuschauer ist im Laufe des
letzten Jahres schon bedeutend
schwieriger geworden Fachleute in
Russland sprechen von einer
unausweichlichen primitivisierung des
Warenangebots wie auch der
Wirtschaftsstruktur einen großen Faktor
stellen dabei hunderte von westlichen
Unternehmen da die in der Zwischenzeit
das Land verlassen haben viele ihrer
Werke stehen seither einfach still
andere wurden an russische
Geschäftspartner oder auch den
startverkauft und was passiert dann
weiter schauen wir uns doch mal zwei
Beispiele anhand euch gut bekannter
Marken an McDonald's Restaurants in
Russland eröffnen wieder unter neuer
Marke die Fast Food-Kette mit dem Namen
Tochter lecker und fertig scheint eine
Kopie des amerikanischen Originals zu
sein richtig meine Lieben Zuschauer
McDonald's
sind geblieben nur der Big Mac
verschwand vorübergehen von der
Speisekarte da gab es wohl Probleme mit
der Lieferkette
in diesem Fall hat ein russischer
Geschäftsmann namens Alexander Goroll
alle McDonald's Restaurants in Russland
aufgekauft er führte bereits eine große
Anzahl von McDonald's Franchises in
näheren Regionen deswegen wusste er
worauf er sich einließ als er das
gesamte Russlandgeschäft übernahmen samt
der Belegschaft von mehr als 60.000
Beschäftigten und er hat sogar
angekündigt weitere Filialen zu eröffnen
in diesem Fall sieht es also so aus als
würde sowohl der russische Konsument als
auch die Volkswirtschaft insgesamt wenig
verlieren Namen und Firmenlogos haben
sich zwar geändert doch Arbeitsplätze
und Warenangebote blieben erhalten warum
das hier so gut geklappt hat nur weil
McDonald's schon immer die Politik
verfolgt maximal viele Zutaten vor Ort
in den Ländern ihrer Standorte zu
produzieren die Marke ist zwar
globalisiert die Lieferanten für
Brötchen Buletten und Salatblätter aber
nicht und wie sieht es in anderen
bedeutendlichen logistikerin Branchen
aus nehmen wir als Beispiel die
Automobilindustrie sie befand sich in
Russland zuletzt praktisch komplett in
der Hand westlicher Autokonzerne die
ihre Modelle nach Russland lieferten
oder in dort neu aufgebauten Fabriken
selbst produzierten auch der Marktführer
die komische massenmarkte Lada gehörte
inzwischen mehrheitlich zum Konzern aber
alle ausnahmslos alle westlichen
Hersteller haben sich vom russischen
Markt zurückgezogen damit so konnte man
meinen eröffnete sich eine Riesenchance
für heimische Hersteller und so stellten
das selbst viele westliche
Medienberichte da russische
Autohersteller Zeit kehrt mit Hilfe
Chinas zurück zwei Jahrzehnte nach ihren
bankrot plant die sowjetische Automarke
moskwitch ein Revival in Russland
Berichten zufolge arbeitet sie mit den
chinesischen Autohersteller JJ zusammen
um trotz des Exodus der großen Marken
Autos zu produzieren das Ganze entpuppte
sich bisher aber als Luftnummer die tote
Automarke moskwitch gehörte der Moskauer
Stadtverwaltung der ihrerseits auf dem
eisigen Werksgelände mitten in Moskau
einem modernen Montage Fabrik zu
gefallen war übrigens zum symbolischen
Kaufpreis von einem Rubel die
moskwitchfertigung nimmt dort aber nur
eine kleine Ecke ein sie besteht aus
folgendem an chinesische kompakt SUVs
werden jede Teile wieder angeschaut die
zuvor ähnliche chinesischen
frisch produzierten Autos abgeschraubt
worden waren und außerdem natürlich
darin ein moskwitch Logo an den
Kühlergrill zu kleben und fertig ist der
moskwitch 3 wie man aus Russland hört
mag unter den dortigen Automobilisten
aber kaum jemand diesen fahrbaren
Etikettenschwindel kaufen zumal die
Mogelpackung mit einem Preis von 2
Millionen Rubel also etwa 24.000 € für
Ivan Normalverbraucher auch verdammt
teuer kommt bis der moskit wie
versprochen besser lokalisiert also
wenigstens partiell aus russischen
Zulieferteil zusammengeschraubt wird und
dann von einem der vorhandenen Renault
Fließbänder rollt wird noch viel Wasser
die mosqua hinunter Fliesen wer sich
aber gerade jetzt in Russland einen
Neuwagen zulegen möchte steht bei
westmarken vor Besen reingeräumten
Showrooms und geht dann notgedrungen zu
jedem Händlern die andere zu 100%
chinesische Marken im Angebot haben die
heißen dann Hawai Cherry Chili xD
tankumodische Und wie auch immer sie
Fluten gerade russlandstraße mit
Crossover an aller Größenklassen glaubt
man nirgendwo sonst Russlands abrupte
Wände nach Osten momentan besser
sichtbar als in den Moskauer notorisch
berüchtigten Verkehrsstaus wer sich als
russischer Autokäufer jedoch patriotisch
Verhalten möchte und
solar-solide russische Autos tja der
wird heftig enttäuscht von den 1.6
Baureihen aus der Renault era werden
momentan real nur drei produziert und
das sind just die ältesten und technisch
primitivsten der Kleinwagen Granta das
in den 70er Jahren entsprungene
geländewagenuhr gestanden haben es nie
war Legend und dessen auch schon
ziemlich angestaubter Nachfolger lieber
travel und selbst bei diesem Modellen
fehlt ist an vielen
Ausstattungsmerkmalen die noch vor zwei
Jahren vollkommen selbstverständlich auf
der Ausstattungsliste standen ist aber
verschwunden sind weil sie wollen
westlichen Zulieferern kam ein typischer
Dialog mit dem russischen freundlichen
sieht jetzt momentan so aus Stress wie
viele Motorvarianten gibt es denn zur
Auswahl sorry eine Automatikgetriebe sie
Weichei wahre Männer schalten selber ABS
ja du gehst nicht so sieht's aus deine
Russland kann man momentan keine neuen
Lada mit ABS kaufen willst du also einen
simplen Lader granter aber halt mit ABS
dann schau nicht besser auf dem
Gebrauchtwagenmarkt um bei den drei
moderneren Modellreihen westtal Lagos
und X-ray kam sogar so viele Bauteile
von Renault oder anderen westlichen
Zulieferern das ihre Produktion vorerst
rot und selbst für die ABS freien
primitiv Modelle sind momentan gewisse
Elektronik Komponenten Mangelware der
leider mutter-konzern after was hat
deswegen schon angekündigt dieses Jahr
die dreiwöchigen bergferien vom Sommer
auf Ende Mai bis Mitte Juni vorzuziehen
der Niedergang der Autoindustrie ist
symptomatisch für die aktuellen Umbrüche
in der russischen Wirtschaft made in
Russia bedeutet im Moment veraltete
Produkte von minderer Qualität und in
minimale Auswahl hergestellt von
Produzenten mit lausiger Produkte und
fragtilität die Talsohle dieser
Mangelwirtschaft ist dabei noch lange
nicht erreicht und das scheint als
Wirtschaftsmodell nur wenig Zukunft zu
haben nicht wahr in der Tat kann wohl
nur eine Strategie der Verstaatlichung
der Wirtschaft oder zumindest der Mass
bundesstaatliche Bezuschussung und dazu
die Erteilung von massiven
Staatsaufträgen hier noch eine
Katastrophe abwenden und tatsächlich
gibt es momentan sehr starke Befürworter
und Tendenzen in Russland wieder eine
zentral gelenkte Planwirtschaft
einzuführen wohin das das letzte Mal
geführt hat brauche ich euch wohl nicht
zu erzählen das zynischste an den ganzen
ist jedoch kurzfristig könnten diese
prioritätenverschiebungen und die
erhöhten Militärausgaben der Regierung
sogar das Bruttoinlandsprodukt auf dem
Papier halbwegs aufrecht erhalten das
erklärt warum einige Organisationen
wieder IWF sogar prognostiziert haben
dass die russische Wirtschaft im Jahr
2023 um 0,3% wachsender diese ganze
Sache hat jedoch eine riesen Haken
staatlich angeordnete Ineffizienz das
heißt Geldverschwendung und die
Produktion von Raketen und Munition
können tatsächlich helfen die
Wirtschaftsdaten eines Jahres zu
verbessern aber sobald das alles
verschossen ist ist es weg alles was
bleibt ist die fette Rechnung die die
Regierung und letztendlich das Volk
bezahlen müssen auch die Produktion
eines Panzers steigert erstmal nominal
das bruttoin Produkt aber damit hat es
sich dann auch anders als andere
Wirtschaftsgüter kurbelt er durch seine
pure Existenz oder seinen Betrieb die
Wirtschaft nicht weiter an gut er könnte
natürlich einen Gewinn bringen wenn er
zu Erbeutung feindlicher
Wirtschaftsgüter führt aber danach sieht
es ja für Russland nicht gerade aus
außer vielleicht ein paar Waschmaschinen
der Panzer wird in der Ukraine also noch
ein bisschen Munition und Treibstoff
verbrauchen aber sobald er auf eine
Miele fährt oder sich eine jeweiligen
Rakete einfängt bleibt nichts als ein
ausgebrannter Haufen Schrott und
vermutlich auch eine Mause tote
Besatzung womit wir wieder beim Problem
mit dem Mangel an Arbeitskräften der
fatalen demografischen Lage und Kredit
Ausfällen werden was ich damit meine
sehen wir gleich aber darin liegt das
große Problem Russland im Moment und
wohl auch in Zukunft ehrlich gesagt wir
von visualpolitik sind keine großen
Chancen das putin ist gelingen könnte
seine nationale Wirtschaft so weit
anzukurbeln dass sie diesen Krieg noch
lange stemmen können könnte schon jetzt
verlangt tut den eigentlich zu viel von
seinem produktiven Sektor und dass der
Bogen überspannt ist zeigt sich denn
auch im eingangs erwähnten
Sektor fünfter April 2023 Russlands
sanktionierte WTB Bank meldet
Rekordverlust von 7,7 Milliarden Dollar
die WTB war eine der ersten Banken die
nach dem Einmarsch der russischen
Streitkräfte in die Ukraine im Februar
2022 aus dem globalen Zahlungssystem
Swift ausgeschlossen wurde sowohl die
USA als auch Großbritannien verhängten
individuelle Sanktion gegen den Chef der
Bank André kostien der ein enger
Vertrauter des russischen Präsidenten
Wladimir Putin ist im Jahr 2021 hatte
die WTB noch eine Nettogewinn von 4,1
Milliarden Dollar erzielt
wohlgemerkt die WTB ist nicht irgendeine
Bank sie ist Russlands zweitgrößter
Kreditgeber über ein Jahr hatte sie
keine Geschäftszahlen gemäß
internationalen Standards mehr
publiziert aber jetzt Plaste die Bombe
dabei hatte die BTB erst im Dezember im
Rahmen einer Rettungsaktion die Pleite
gegangene Bank und kretier für 4,7
Milliarden Dollar gekauft die russische
Zentralbank musste diese Übernahme mit
rund 2 Milliarden Dollar versüßen da
sonst auch die WTB
kapitalisierungsprobleme bekommen hätte
schließlich hatte die WWW nicht nur
sanktionsbedingt ihre Assets im Westen
verloren sondern auch massive
Kreditausfälle in Russland eingefahren
und 4,8 Milliarden Dollar und welche
Kredite waren da vor allem ausgefallen
nun setzt euch lieber hin denn jetzt
wird's noch mal richtig Marke diese
Kredit Ausfälle gehen zu einem großen
Teil darauf zurück dass die Bank allen
mobilisierten Soldaten die in der
Ukraine kämpfen einen Zahlungsaufschub
gewähren musste verzeiht mir bitte an
dieser Stelle das Wort Zahlungsaufschub
aber diesen Euphemismus hat sich der
Sprecher der WT ausgedacht es dürfte
schließlich ziemlich klar sein dass
viele dieser armen mobickie niemals
wieder in der Lage sein werden ihre
Schulden zurückzuzahlen damit aber genug
für heute vergesst bitte nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen um das folgevideo nicht zu
verpassen und wenn ihr das erledigt habt
würde mich noch eure eigene Meinung
interessieren was meint ihr kann
Russland wirklich das gesamte Arsenal
ersetzen dass seine Armee gegenwärtig
verheizt inwieweit wird Russland in der
Lage sein moderne präzisionsmunition in
der benötigten Menge herzustellen und
werden wird tatsächlich erleben dass
Russland eine echte Kriegswirtschaft
einführt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video etwas gebracht hat und mir
vielleicht auch was dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like und
teilt es mit euren Freunden um es
ausgiebig zu diskutieren natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit uns hält dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]